he's Bob Saget zero-to-sixty stand-up
special available right now on Amazon
iTunes right here on DirecTV other
platforms it's 150 platforms it's like a
subway it's like that but it's the first
time it's ever happened cuz normally
Netflix or HBO's your drool in the crown
is of course most notable noticeably but
this is like everywhere it's it's
Comcast it's everything you can't say
cuz this building is but it but it's a
pretty fantastic all over the world it
had dropped last week that's enough
about my testicle but I might love to
say that you you most certainly can look
at Bob it's a free country if you want
to come on there's a re country if you
want to watch then you want to come on
here and talk about your gonads Bob
Saget you go on with your bad self all
right all right so my gonads are
available all over the world and they
dropped last week and I can't wait to
New Year's when they drop again and
they're special they're like you're
special there they are
zero to 60 I have a little dreidel I
made it out of clay very good and you
also just eliminated most of your
audience no no not at all and where
there there are more people joining now
because I'm here they arm their gonad
loving people objecting yeah I would
well let's put it this way I hope so I
hope says to name a kid nad and then
when he's running we're gonna add and
you motivated huh it's like run Forrest
mad Saget that's a WoW I think he's a
rapper I think he's gonna do great mad
or DJ to some DJ make 5 million dollars
you know that used to be a day if your
kid was a DJ bunny or three beautiful
children yes what's a DJ you go oh my
god my kids a DJ but it's like now it's
like a DJ Khaled it makes an absurd
amount of money I finally am bucks your
kid can make so I'm saying live off your
kids yeah it's the idea one of my kids
who were is here in the back right now
coop picked up a ball with his left hand
and I'm like that means he might be able
to pitch till he's 50 years old and
there were four jokes in there that I'm
not touching because it's your kid does
give me one what's the what's one of the
four jokes you can't can't because well
sports is fascinating because whenever
you say look a little looks better he's
given Lex that's good
nobody but sports is you know the old
joke Yakov Smirnoff you know poor balls
you walk you know he didn't understand
the game because you walk you walk proud
that's the guy what a country yeah what
a country in America you have balls and
Russia balls have you you know but now
he's fixing a luncheon right I don't
know what he's doing he's not what he
makes vodka he is fixing an election
from Branson Missouri
that's Branson did he really gaze back
here in LA and he's a sweet guy the
Russian you can treat known you'd
actually have known him well I have
Russian roots okay
that's how I grow my beets no do you
have roots and like I think it was a
beet name a vegetable you should do my
show talk about your gonads and
vegetables with the roots and then we'll
promote your special and send you on
your way that's what we talked about
what do we plan don't we followed the
plan so far here right but we're
entertaining people right now and that's
I'm coming on to be well I am you you
are you're laughing you you don't always
laugh you take sports very seriously you
know everything about everything I try
you always have that's next um and I'm
trying to be a little silly right now in
my general demeanor on camera because
I've been on this press tour for my
special yes you've been everywhere by
the way I've been trying and different
places people's homes I just show up on
the roof but but the key is to try to be
silly in to try and entertain is what
I've been you always know that's what I
do anyway yeah but but thoughtfully
we're all in a time where everything is
hurting so bad that one of the relief
valve is entertainment it is sports it
is it is a game and and that's what
you're doing you're doing something
wonderful for people this is because
every day you wake up you read something
you go well I mean and now I see
something trending I
name trending I think the person's
either dead or a sexual harasser or
something like that you just never know
who's name is no I thought you meant the
same person and got confused it's a dead
sexual harasser well that would now be
the most 20 2017 thing there would be
out there so it's gonna be a great we
were I was talking with my fiancee today
my accounts yes you can't say but Rose
you've brought well you brought guys
Kelly sitting on our honor our tiny man
couch as we call it here he loves tiny
man couches this is why she that's why
she's with you right yes I have an
ottoman in every room but I'm the king
of the Ottoman Empire I didn't know that
you're Russian now you say you're
turkish you're confusing me I don't know
I I do like the hookah
I like the party I like the disco I like
to hookah so you were talking about
Kelly yeah I was just I don't know what
I was talking about but it had to do it
I think it had to do with entertaining
people right now and that we were
talking about there should be a calendar
of all the news that comes out every day
whether it be a tweet or whether it be
the headline because you could have that
months and I'm not gonna give examples
because it's also painful yes everybody
accused and it's not funny it's dark
comedy and it's no laughing matter I
know that I know
so we wake up to no laughing matter we
wake up to something where our heart
hurts well I mean all I want to do is
have some fun and I got the feeling I'm
not the only one oh I'm with you you
know I'm gonna possess Sheryl Crow you
know I I picked it up man that was
social club know what's great about you
more than a poker face no I don't mean
like Lady gaga I mean when I say
something to you I mean you don't
respond and that's because your brain is
so big and active I'm listening I'm
meeting your parents and they never knew
you'd had this much DNA in your skull I
don't think well I think it I owe it all
to them did you know he was smart when
he was very very young you're asking a
Jewish mother a question was it was he
always very very smart did he borrow
money did he did I borrow money mom did
I borrow my mom's giving you kind of a
half oh yeah yes it did
did he make interest did he always make
money yes always made money yeah
you put you're very talkative my parents
are also television savvy they know
they're not mic duct yes they're very
nice I wish I had I wish I had my parent
I know you talked about that the last
time that you were here yeah about Jenna
and my new special about that I want to
promote it in my book I talked about my
dad a lot no no and in my special
zero-to-sixty which I don't want to
promote too much but it's available
everywhere Amazon and iTunes in every
literally every viral platform but I
talk about my mom and my mom in it it
gets kind of serious in the middle
because she said when she was leaving us
that she was going to come back as a
dove and I said please don't do that
and so I'm scared of doves because you
never know if that's your mom
well good if you go to a magic act or
you go to see right now this is my poker
face because I don't know if you're
being serious it's in the special okay
anything completely ludicrous that I
tell you is in the special
isn't the special but it's an it's an
entertainment special is and I think you
guys I want you and Susie to watch it
okay we test with you when you called in
to our podcast yeah it was really sweet
are you guys naked when you do that we
are not we're fully dressed
onesies no no no the way that we act
like right now the way I'm dressed which
is just very cushy that is so and we hug
before that's exactly what you said you
were so soft that's not a good thing
though no I didn't the sweater let's
take a break we're back in 60 seconds I
wanted did you hear what Mike Leach had
to say about matrimony no I did he
sounded great Mike Mike leeches
matrimony I got a cupcake you gotta have
a cupcake you got I don't know zero to
60 check it out right now I'm is on
iTunes DirecTV other platforms we come
back with Bob Saget we'll get you ready
for the Thanksgiving weekend when we
come back in just 60 seconds
[Music]
all right welcome back to the Rich Eisen
show our friends at Funny or Die have
provided us with some some comedy that
we're gonna give you at the end of the
at the end of the show the the Funny or
Die pitch app has provided us some great
lines from some great writers about what
some sports stars are thankful for this
Thanksgiving holiday I'm thankful for
Bob Saget hanging with me here on the
show and bow I love talking about this
because again your everyone knows you're
funny and you can work blue and you work
serious as well but you got a huge heart
disclaimer disclaimer derma Research
Foundation which you found it help find
or be part of yeah right since my friend
Sharon manske founded it and then I
became part of it as your sister got
sick after I became parties that that I
did not know it was you got involved
because of your sister it's such a rare
disease scleroderma or it affects mostly
women in the prime of their lives
and there's hundreds of thousands of
people with with the disease and my
sister came down with this disease we
didn't know what it was but I'd already
been doing the benefit for three years
the first person that ever do it was
Robin Williams and Robin did the benefit
and he's a giant loss that will always
feel sure he did the benefit seven times
and seven he doesn't say no he'd just
show up what do you need chief chief
will hmm
make some money and we've raised forty
five million dollars in five years your
40th event is coming up in Tuesday in
New York City and and the people that
show off it's a testament to how much
you are loved and beloved and who shows
up here you got Jeffrey Ross again I
mean he's always there he's like a
family
he's the remember you had an event
recently in Los Angeles Susie and I came
to it i CLE was two or three years ago
you got Kimmel Conan Craig Ferguson was
on the air at the time as well Leno
showed up I mean you got every single
those are two different ones but but I
like the combo the well you've got
pretty much every active Regis los
angeles-based late-night TV host at the
last Kimmel has been over-the-top
amazing and and then the last one in LA
we raised 1.4 million dollars it's kind
it was with Ray Romano and Jim and Jim
Gaffigan and gone together and Bill burr
and it's harder so many of my friends
yeah and comedians are all stepping
you know their their dilemmas in the
world right now
and most of the comedians are right on
it the one in New York that's December
5th which I'm very proud of is it's
gonna be Jeff Ross and it's gonna be
Michael che John Oliver George Lopez and
Jackson Browne's gonna sing so and
that's for you know 400 people at
Caroline's who we do it every year in
New York and we raise 700 grand there
last time and that money goes right to
research to help all these people that
have that have not getting any then not
gotten any Jed Clampett but they but
they had no government funding and so we
do it privately and it's quite a miracle
that we've raised so much I'm reading
off the screen srf CC HC org exactly CC
HC org for more information there again
if December 5th Caroline's on Broadway
and you know you do that stuff all the
time and now in congratulations you are
engaged as we talked about before yes
she said yes which is convenient how did
you probably wouldn't be here if I said
no question Paul how did I pop it
well I am this - is this - person no it
went all over it traveled so I thought
it would be boring but I'll tell you
because it's exciting I mean it's love
it's based on love and the world we're
in right now if somebody loves somebody
yes and if a dude is like nice to the
his woman and the woman is nice to the
dude I mean the dude I know that Jeff
Bridges if I know well we had the duty
or we had the dude here about a month
ago
are you kidding what am I doing here
cuz you're Bob freakin Saget yeah but I
mean Jeff freakin bridges I know
so anyway question well we were watching
stranger things up in Northern
California okay
true that uh-huh and and then I took a
break and I'd had a ring in the safe she
didn't know it okay and I went in and
got it and then I got on one knee and I
asked her and the joke is it became a
joke because it's so stupid I was trying
to come up with a different way how did
you ask Susie did you say I want to
spend the rest of my life with you oh no
it was in nap
California I got a gazebo raised ah so
it was a it's a high up gazebo in the
bedroom no it was in a vineyard and a
vineyard he Suns going down
and I hid I hid the the box and the
bottle of champagne in the corner of the
of the gazebo oh this is nice
no one else is around no one else around
Sun Goes Down I proposed to her I said
will you marry me and she said yes and
then asked me to do it again cuz it she
just wasn't she said what's in it for me
that's been the Lexx that's been the
next 16 hours absolutely no so so mine
was baima's him Big Sur yeah which is
beautiful yeah and four days are gone by
where we were staying somewhere and we
were about to leave but I kind of just
planned it to do it at the end and
surprise her and I instead of saying I
want to spend the rest of my life with
you I said would you spend whatever time
I have left at least is that you're
still that's it's the worst rule of
improv it's not even there's not even a
yes except she said yes she said she
would you stop stranger things do that
which I saw you raised and we just got
back to the stranger things two days ago
we caught up your best we binge watch to
save our relationship a new meaning to
Netflix and chill I think you've raised
that unless you're watching fuller house
but it's hard to chill if you're
watching me play a thirty-year-old
character what do you think of Mike
leeches advice the coach of Washington
State is part of it I think he there are
meds for him it's the general theory
behind what he's saying the general
theory is that guys need to just stay
out of the way when marriage is taking
place because there's just it's a no-win
situation just say yes just yeah do you
ask the question to which hopefully she
says yes yes and then the rest of the
time it's now on you to just say yes no
matter what but then you don't you lose
who you are ass and your masculine don't
you lose what is the good parts about
being a man
well in bringing yourself to a relation
between your so being yourself but then
we can be so petulant you you can you
and I probably have a lot in common that
way I know that I can be petulant I can
argue over things that are meaningless
and then there's a reason for it well I
would be never does that I would agree
with you but I'm perfect Bob can I tell
you what does Susie say I'm Susie Susie
do you think Susie runs the show if you
just met her
what are you kidding yeah I think we
have similar relationship God eat the
cupcake I don't even British what's his
deal was he from no i idly just from I
think he's from the state of Texas where
I think leach is from but wait hey Bob
look have a great Thanksgiving holiday
have a wonderful holiday bet at Bob
Saget on Twitter again check out the new
stand-up special relatively new
zero-to-sixty amazon itunes many other
platforms here on DirecTV as well for
the TV audience would you mind turkey
bowling with my children who have come
out I want a turkey bowl with your child
but everybody's a turkey not your child
it's not a metaphor for anything that's
literally a frozen turkey and my special
is not you relatively new its new
obviously hopefully it's better than you
just drop like mine add bring my
children out to hang out with Bob Saget
Denny's fiction a child nad Saget
that's next the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience